let's see the opening in the topology
it's another
another joko pianissimo
magnus probably sees no reason to
deviate from what he did in the
classical yeah here we are a5
and that we saw rookie one bishop a7
yeah i'm again we've seen a lot of white
players go for bishop g5 here which
they usually consider too too risky and
classical but then they must win
might as well let's see if topalov joins
the team no he goes rookie one again
show a7
and knight bd2 to power not deviating
either
castles
i have one i wonder if magnus would say
you know what i didn't like the
structure from the last game i'll
i'll try to play play another move like
knight e7 here is also possible
and yeah that's what he does he goes
knight e7 he says no more bishop e6 for
you sir
makes a lot of sense
keeps the position flexible
and uh
magnus
of course starting with a three minute
deficit but has draw odds
and i can tell you still no decision
made in the
versus timor rajabov
game he still has to move his queen ah
he moved it back to e1
keep an eye on it probably we should
switch to when we're telling you yep
let's go back
even lower here it's a
actually very close to symmetrical
position if white played a4 rook e8
would be fully symmetrical
so not that much happening
some preparation
and now he regains it on d4
yeah he's fine
yeah
it looks like a
magnus is fine so everything is calm
there but it's not calm
in the armageddon
yep
still fine
and i will keep you posted on whatever
shakria does
yeah here the game is simplified
somewhat cousin regained his pawn
on d4
and is now
exchanging this bishop so it's opposite
colored bishops
just to be a little careful
that there are no
attacks against h7 but c5
fortifying this bishop on d4 and then if
needed g6
still looks like black is doing all
right
yep
d1 maybe the power just wants to take it
okay six fancy
i told you that's his uh trademark
get the rook
to an open horizontal line and swing
that rug across
swing it
or shake it
um
oh very nice move from magnus
h g3 g3
somehow it feels like
e8 i was thinking if you go rookie 6 and
f6 maybe you can
think about some fun on the f line but
this is
it's losing sight of f7 though it's nice
move by topalov b4
now if a takes b bishop takes
you're not happy to have your rook on e8
so oh
we'll play it by vaseline and this could
be
okay it was a little careless and losing
sight
of that ball yep and uh shaq has made a
move carson all of a sudden worse
after b4 he's i think in serious trouble
he probably has to take bishop takes and
then
go back with the rook which is not
something you love doing
and with this extra time with e6 looming
it's it's a little unpleasant for for
the world champion
he's also losing time now trying to
figure out how to deal with this b4
which came that's an unpleasant surprise
so carlson some trouble whoa
look at this
carlson delivering a tactical blow
bishop c4 rook f
six
swinging
but okay the question is
if you capture that pawn sorry if you
capture that rook
should be fine queen e4
and the end games are at least drawn
yep
so you have to go away that's what
vaseline does queen g4
and uh now you can't capture the pawn
because rook takes bishop is in the air
g6 queen e2
carlson down to two minutes but tepalav
also only has three and top is
not known to be a specialist for having
very little time on the clock so he also
has to be careful yep magnus is much
more experienced in blitz and bullet so
if the clocks get really low should
favor the world champion yeah and there
is a threat on the board of playing rook
to b2
offering up a trade and he steps forward
with his king
but uh i liked your bishop b5 that kind
of restricted the range of that rook
so now rook b2 forcing the white rook to
step forward but now there's a trade and
this
will help magnus in his quest for that
draw
yeah simplification's useful but this
structure is still dangerous for black
b5 is a nice move
and
i would
can you take it yes if bishop b5 queen
b7 is the trick yep he's taken it
i mean but how tricky is it bishop quite
tricky
because if bishop d3 does rook takes e5
and he gets rid of
his main enemy this pawn on e5 which was
really restricting
his pieces
and if bishop takes the eight queen e4
followed by queen e5 it's just a draw
sir
nice that's a very nice spot with very
limited time
i mean certainly a nice spot but i mean
is there still some danger i'm just
thinking
that the age pawn can start making your
way its way me ah it's way up the board
i don't think so i think it's just equal
now
okay
and all the while shaq has not made a
move against rajabov so he's still
pondering over whether to
play the queen to the center to e4 or to
capture the pawn
and that's it we have a result he's done
after this b5 queen b7 good spot by
carlson was on some pressure that saves
himself there with b5